there is a lot more to the coveted
relief bill than funding for the
vaccination effort and the 1400
stimulus checks here to tell us about
all of this is cbs news senior business
analyst jill schlesinger
jill good to see you it's been it's been
way too long so in the last
year now the government has spent more
than five trillion
dollars what is different about this
third version
i think what's really important in this
version is that it's tilted more
towards the low to middle income earners
you know with all of the different
elements which we will discuss today
you are going to see a reduction by
one third of poverty that's 50 for child
poverty you're going to see incomes rise
for the
lowest fifth of earners by 20
middle-income people gonna see increases
by more than five and a half percent
after taxes jeff
so this is much more geared towards low
to the middle
income earners you know jill we're still
talking about how they got those checks
so fast but more importantly what data
is the irs
basing this on well it really is
dependent on when you file
taxes you know we are in the middle of
tax season which is a little bit of
unnerving for some people
but if the irs has your record from 2019
they'll base it on that
if you've already filed for 2020 they'll
base it on that if there's any change
you will be able to get it back the irs
is going to try to automate that
but keep an eye on where's my refund
where's my check go to irs.gov to figure
that one out
joe what are some of the other
provisions for families that they're
going to see
well i think in addition to those 1400
checks which are really important but
also are going to
older dependents a lot of people
complain my college kids don't get a
check i claim them
you'll get them for any dependent on
your tax returns
but we are seeing a significant increase
to the
child tax credit that used to be two
thousand dollars for
low to middle income earners the income
range is expanded now
and the child tax credit goes from two
thousand to three
thousand thirty six hundred dollars if
your kids are under the age of six so
very big
earned income tax credit expanded the
affordable care act premiums are coming
down
we are seeing an expansion of the cobra
benefits so if people have insurance
from their employer
and they want to keep that insurance the
government's going to help subsidize
that this year
so a lot in this package and a lot of
this is going to take some figuring out
for
people as they go through the next
coming months and jill quickly something
a lot of us have been thinking about
these small independent restaurants in
particular that have been hit so
hard during the pandemic there's help in
here for them as well right
yes 28 billion dollars and this has been
a real
hard lobbying effort for the last year
this industry has been
slammed we are seeing leisure and
hospitalities lost two million jobs
we have seen a hundred ten thousand
restaurants close in the united states
240 billion dollars just vanished so
this is very much a
needed component to keeping some of the
restaurants alive
that really can survive money for those
who need it most and they're getting it
fast jill thank you for
the perspective on this